ガチャガチャがやりたくてアマゾンで探したんですよガチャガチャの本体が欲しい方
持ってアマゾンで探してたら6000円くらいだったんですよ
6000円ぐらいでガチャガチャ本体が売っててなんかあやしいなぁと思ったんですよ
6000円でガチャガチャの本当に帰るんですよ怪しいと思って色々調べたらちゃんと
公式のが坂者ですって書いてあって帰ろうと思って買って届きま
した6円で家で画像物できるのか通って買ったんですけど
小さいね小さいねー小さい約1/2さんって帰ったり側まだ完全偽物だよ
いき誤って肉買っちゃったよ目が掘られちゃんねなんかおもちゃよおもちゃ売っちゃっ
たちーさんもちゃないわこれはただのおもちゃだよ
というわけでちゃんと本物を見つけてきましたいざ開封
[音楽]
ちょっとちょっと待って怖いなぁちょっと怖いなぁかや傘本来傷ついたらすごいこわー
a これで謎3壊れてたら俺もやなぁ
これですよこれじゃあコレを待ってたんだよ扱おう
もうこれでこれこれこれもっとずっと1世号4
すごい馬ってほんとじゃあデーター
ん
moon
pa
パイプで言う訳年間に1手に入れることができましたガッツ赤ちゃんでございまホント
ねガチャガチャは欲しかったこれが家にあるってももうをところ好きだったらこれは
実際に家に置いておきたかっ右折あるブーブー匹猫個で100円のまあ何枚入れたら
マセラティですね
なんかん
ああなにこれはレギュラーが落ちてきちゃったこれでこの中に物を入れるんですよね
ゲイナーなぜそもそも僕ガチャガチャなんて買ったかって言いますと自分の
ガチャガチャを作りたいんですよ
自分でガチャガチャを作りたかったよくいろんなバカ猿じゃないですか何か何が出るか
分からないガチャとか声援ガチャとかああいうガチャ科猪ってだいたい出るのかもう
ある程度決まってるんですよねよくわかんない腕はと
かなんでこんなの売ってるの見たら靴妹とかあんまり売れなかったが辛さのあまりとか
だいたい2 ia なんか何言ってるかわかんないけどちゃってるのが出てきまってる
と思うんですよねって半径ができる
そんなんじゃまだまだ甘え俺は俺だけど俺のオリジナリティ溢れる自分だけど
ガチャガチャマシーンが作りたいと思ったのでカチャカチャの購入しましたまたでも
カプセルなくねやってカプセル買った彼
何回使ってる自分で買ったみたいですこういう
時だけ準備んすよああ
これでちゃんとできるかやってみましょうこんなに誰かどうか確かめないと
いきます
ぜひぜひとできたここから中身に僕はものを中で入れて本当に私が自分で作った
ガチャガチャ調教は皆さんに披露したいと思います行くぜ
[音楽]
単位てあげて僕の方々完成しました伝説のガチャ
生まれ変われもう一人の国編1回100円でございますなんかに入っているものは
もちろんポカなかなか他では見られない部屋ものパーカー1回100円だと手に入ら
ないようなもう言ってみたんですけどもこれからちょっとのいろんなお客さんが僕時に
包んだよちょっとみんなにグッズ画像をやってもらってハッピーな気持ちになって
もらいたいと思います
誰だよ
voodoo
がじゃあ
1片
はぁ
ああああああ
ていた
まっちょっ
バッハ
えっ
[音楽]
なんでなんでヲカマ5分ないでしょ南寧に
th
だーっ
メイクぜんぜんっ
ん
コレなにまで他に入れなきゃダメでしょこれ他に入れるのこれお金入れるお金入れ
なきゃダメだってこれ
ていました
ません
はいこれはおじゃましまーすぱじみっくん
動作の
ホッ
頑張ってクリーミーカフェショップこれと言って変わったれ
早実際なって磨きたい
bb だー
イーリーデー ee ラガー
ボスて来なかったですか放置てこないよ気をよくわかってらっしゃったんですけど入っ
ていっ協力開けてくださいといけない
鍾支社残っ
ミート株価なポイントなんだなんかやっぱりここは今勇気はそうだねえっつー
う bb 弾が散った0
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ